some breaking news now and an inquest
jury has concluded that uzman khan the
terrorist who murdered two people before
being shot dead by police on london
bridge
was lawfully killed let's speak to our
crime correspondent martin brunt
who's in central london for us martin
what more can you tell us
yes a verdict of lawful killing which
really wasn't in any doubt
and it was a verdict the coroner had
told
jurors was the only verdict that they
could
bring he directed them in fact
rather spoon-fed it to them before lunch
when he sent them out to start their
deliberations
so it was hardly an arduous task for
them he said
the only verdicts they could arrive at
was lawful killing
and he said that was really based on the
testimony during this inquest from the
officers who
had well six of them who had fired 20
shots at usman khan who had all in their
evidence
made it clear that they were concerned
for their own
safety and the safety of other people on
london bridge
at the time shortly after usman khan had
stabbed to death
two people inside fishmongers hall at
that prison
education conference and injured
three others so the verdict was one
thing
delivered in the last few minutes the
coroner
also asked the jurors to write what he
described as a narrative
he said it doesn't have to be long one
or two paragraphs
just the sort of means uh the means
and circumstances of usman khan's death
and they did that and they
described the fake suicide belt
that khan was found to be wearing
after he died but at the time all those
officers who gave evidence said that
they were convinced was a real
explosive device the jurors described
that as very realistic
so accepting the evidence of the
officers
the jurors in this narrative also talked
about the officer who fired
the first two shots at khan
and they said that that was done to
incapacitate him
and to reduce the risk to the public
also in the narrative the jurors have
said that police interpreted
later usman khan's attempts having been
shot
twice attempts to sit up as
a move to detonate the device which at
that stage everybody still thought
was a viable explosive device device so
it would appear from that narrative that
the jurors have accepted
in total the evidence of the various
police officers who gave evidence during
the hearing